pew put out a study that said that 78 of
women would not date a partner or not
get with a a prospective mate that did
not make more than they did and only 48
of men shared that uh view
[ __ ] man
and you know
no sorry go ahead
you have an ever
increasing group of high performing
women competing for an ever decreasing
group of ultra high performing men
and the choice is that the analogy that
i always use is it's the same as being
the tall girlfriend
now if you're a six foot one without
heels on woman
you're looking at professional athletes
because on average women want to date a
man that is about 21 centimeters taller
than her yes that's another uh yes
uh statistic pull there um
interestingly men prefer to date a woman
that's i think 16 centimeters or 12
centimeters shorter than him so even in
that and this is this is such a perfect
example right
women want them
to date a man on average that's 21
centimeters taller men on average want
to date a woman that is 16 centimeters
shorter
in that we have a disparity we have the
preference of a man and the preference
of a woman both moving in opposite
directions but not marrying up
yes yes so the the
the missing point here is not just the
preference of a woman because from from
the conversation we're having we're
discussing female mate preferences but
what is loss here are male made
preferences what they're looking for in
a perspective made so we talk about
women i haven't even spoken about that
yeah men do men don't matter
but but even looking at what men desire
in a partner
there you know there's that notion that
there's a new 18 year old every day and
so these women that are achieving uh
quite a bit you know economically
speaking educationally speaking are
going to be on average much older than
women just entering the bloom of their
life so they're competing against
women who are on average more attracted
or more attractive to males because if
it is the case that men are attracted to
youth and fertility you're down you're
behind the eighth ball if if you're 35
with a phd
competing against an 18 year old an 18
year old that is just
doesn't
hasn't had that much life experience but
is quite attractive to uh works at
starbucks but she's fertile as [ __ ]
exactly
exactly it's it's it's a tough sell it's
it's a
horribly unfair
dynamic
the asymmetries go all the way down man
i mean you said so here's another thing
that some of the girls that are
listening
may have realized
if
being smart and rich and high status is
negatively correlated with men being
attracted to you and with success in
relationships
that may lead some women to signal that
they are
less smart and less educated and less
wealthy than they are and i think that
you found a study that
showed
women under-reporting
their education level in certain
circumstances when around men
this is correct so this is referencing i
believe a a harvard um uh business
school study so looking at um
declarations of of um you know personal
success or wanting to become something
later on down the line and when it was
the case that uh women could
confidentially report their their
ambitions they would do so honestly but
when it was known that people would
actually realize or recognize them uh
they would actually tamp down their
ambitions so as to not make it seem as
though they were ambitious
and it logically links the fact that um
they'd be less attractive to a man
because she was a boss [ __ ] career
career woman
it's uh jordan peterson
ism to say is it for every standard
deviation that a woman uh goes above the
normal iq
yes uh point that she's 30 less likely
to get married i can state the exact
statistics so uh it was a study
conducted by four universities here in
the uk
and it was found by that for every 16
point increase for a man in iq his
prospect of marriage increases by 35
percent but for every 16 point increase
in a woman's iq her prospect of marriage
decreases by 40 percent
what do we do about that
what do you do about that statistic
i i don't know that you do anything
about it again it's
all of what we're discussing here are
just
inherent facts of the human condition
about dating sexual dynamics and all of
this is premised on on evolutionary
precepts and there i don't think there's
anything you can do about it
i don't think there's anything you can
do about it as sad as that sounds unless
you want to settle
because it's almost like you'd have to
if you're a female and i do feel for
young girls particularly if i have a
daughter
in the future i definitely would feel
for her because that you have ambitions
and you want to be something you want to
be someone you want to achieve all these
things and make quite a bit of money
good for you you should aim for that
sort of thing but it comes with the
consequence of knowing that men that you
are looking to get with in a long-term
relationship aren't interested in those
things
and
you're not going to be as attractive as
again the 18 year old
it's a difficult thing that
competence in many domains is not
something which is seen as attractive by
the sex that you're trying to attract as
a woman and also actually can be
detrimental
that you being competent working hard to
get a job to
grow a career to get status to earn
money to become educated all of these
things are actually making it more
difficult for you to do it and on top of
that they use up the single most
important resource and the most
attractive quality you have which is
time and your use yes you spend your 20s
getting educated
building up your career and earning
money to find out that men don't care
about your education level your career
or your wealth and now you're so you're
older than some women who you're now
trying to compete with that's
it's not kicking the balls uh it's a
kick in there's something else about
that's a punch of the tits it's a punch
in the tit it's a punch in the tit
you're correct
um
ah [ __ ] man this this
entire subject area fascinates me
because of how uncomfortable it is
um
you know
we are bound by our evolutionary
precepts as you called them to just
and and the final thing as well is like
the fundamental choice that you have
left as a woman
is to
as most women on average
if this hypergamous nature ends up
continuing and if the uh how would you
say the
over success of women continues to
accelerate uh is you have two choices as
far as i can see one of them is to
move through life and be single and the
other one is to settle with a mate that
you are fundamentally unattracted to
neither of those seem like particularly
good situations the only advantage that
women have over men in this you know
average value women and average valued
men the only advantage that the women
have is the fact that they can settle
and the men don't even have that
opportunity
it's it's a tough spell to swallow but
the worst part about it is that is not
that it's it's a reality and it it it
will most likely move to being more
palatable as time goes on at least
that's my contention what do you mean
it's the fact well it's in the sense
that it the worst part about is that we
don't know about it
that's the worst part about it is that
it's it's it's certainly the shark in
the waters right it's jaws and is that
it this is a creeping
disaster that is is on the frontier that
no one is particularly informed about
and the whole point of this article was
to or these set of articles was to ring
an alarm bell to say that this is
definitely an issue that we need to be
taking a very close look at because it's
not just that it's an issue that can be
that is
that damages an economy for example it
might damage an economy but it's it's an
issue that damages the society and long
term civilization yeah civilization yes
civilization ending what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you